she's very independent I don't doubt  that 18 she will move out for sure Kim  Zolciak Biermann responds to her  daughter asking to be emancipated I'm  telling mom and dad that I want to be  emancipated fine I found out you can be  emancipated when you're 16 and I really  want that because my parents are very  strict that was Kim's a 13 year old  daughter Ariana on Sunday night's  episode of don't be tardy making some  surprising comments which grabbed a lot  of headlines  so when ichi caught up with kim after  the Dancing with the Stars premiere we  had to get her take on the whole thing  Ariana just kind of says stuff she's  very independent I don't doubt that 18  she will move out for sure but I mean  she doesn't want to go anywhere she  knows she's got a pretty cushy life I am  strict tough crap basically you're 13  honey